Joe just uh what What's the next step
for you with James and like as a 10 I'm
going forward and how much you're going
to be in his ear this summer to kind of
have him come back here
um we got a an unfinished you know
job well we we had we haven't won
anything and I think you know we we we
you know we got the chance
um you know to win uh you know obviously
going going to seven games and uh you
know having a chance to close it out at
home which we didn't do
um I still believe uh we got the you
know we got the chance to win uh we got
what it takes to win so
obviously I don't know what's going on
that I know he has a player option so
they can extend him so but that's on you
know those guys who you know figured it
out I'm gonna stay out of it but I still
believe that you know me and them and
you know we got the chance to win but
you know it's going to take you know
more than us we all gotta look at
ourselves
I got to be better and I will be better
that's what I'm focused on
um you know all of us we gotta you know
come back and find ways to just keep
improving and you know help the team you
can't win alone I can't win alone I
can't me and James we just can't win
alone you know that's why basketball is
played five on five so you know we just
need everybody to just you know try to
keep finding ways to get better and uh
you know we'll be fine